Bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur ma chaîne Youtube.
Vous l'avez peut-être constaté sur les réseaux sociaux,
chaque jour en cette période de confinement,
je partage avec vous un
nouveau savoir en vous faisant profiter
de mon petit bout de jardin quand il
fait beau ou de mon atelier.
Une "capsule de déconfiné" en
quelque sorte, "Chez Jamy".
Suite à vos nombreuses sollicitations,
j'ai décidé de franchir le pas
et de créer ma propre chaîne Youtube.
Alors pour le moment, vous allez y retrouver
ces capsules quotidiennes mais dès que
le confinement sera terminé eh bien vous
pourrez découvrir d'autres formats.
J'y parlerai de mes émissions, de mes livres.
Des lieux insolites que je découvre.
Pour vous abonner, il suffit de cliquer !
Encore une fois, merci beaucoup
pour tous vos messages généreux et encourageants,
à très bientôt et surtout n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien